Hey there! Thanks for coming out today
and joining us to learn a little bit
about how you would deploy SAP into the cloud.
And I know that this is a terrifying incredibly complicated solution.
It's the kind thatsends chills and shutters down the back of any CIO who's about to go down this road,
butit doesn't have to be.
It's a fairly basic process from a conceptual standpoint.
It's the execution that's the hard part.
And so, how we're going to answer this is
we're going to go through the logical steps
of how you actually go through the process of
deploying SAP onto the cloud,
to try and demystify it, to make it a little more straightforward.
So that you, as you're doing all of your planning,
can incorporate these steps into figuring out yourtimelines, figuring out your budgets,
but most importantly, hopefully you can take away someadvice and some lessons learned from this video
so that you don't have to experience the pain thatsome of our other clients have had over time.
And so, when we talk about deploying SAP on thecloud,
probably the first and most important part,
and arguably the longest part of your process, needs to be number 1
- and that number 1 is you must evaluate your existing landscape.
And when you evaluate that that landscape, it's not just a matter of sizing,
you know, howbig is it today, how big is it going to get in the future -
if all you talk is tech, you're missingthe boat.
The evaluation piece has to be about your business.
Moving to the cloud needs to have
a reason.
You don't do it just because it's fun,
or just because you've got extra money that youneed to spend.
You need to define: what are the success criteria?
What problems am I solving,
and is moving to the cloud going to answer those problems?
If you haven't answered thosequestions yet, don't start on this journey.
Work on the business challenge first,
because ifthe only thing you do is move to cloud
without addressing any of the other challenges youalready have,
your cloud migration is never going to be successful.
It's only going toadd additional difficulty to your life.
So, once you've done that evaluation, once youhave gotten out,
and you've said, "These are our goals, this is what we're going to fix, this isour success criteria,
and this is how we're goingabout it",
then it's time to step in and say, "OK,what do we do first?"
Well, so working with your system integrator, the first thing you're going todo,
is you're going to bring up some Dev systems, right?
So that those Dev systems, these arelittle.
These are not big systems, they're small systems,
and the purpose of the Dev systems
is to do some little baby proofs of concept, right?
You're going to do a little POC work,
you're going to do a little bit of testing on them.
You're going to make sure that the infrastructure that you think you're going to use
is going to be successful in the way that you intend to use it.
That's the purpose of Dev.
You're also going to start trying to figure out
how to move all my customizations,
how to move all of my data around,
because coming from on-premises
into the cloud is not a trivial challenge.
You need to start doing some of your data mapping withthese Dev systems, right?
How do I get data in, how do I get data out?
And so, once you've gotyour Dev, then it's time to start bringing up the big systems, right?
And I'm going to call this"Stage",
and the reason that I'm going to call it Stage is because eventually
the second set thatyou bring up this is going to be your staging environment.
So, a normal flow would go from Dev
into Stage.
So, your normal SAP progression is going to go from Dev into Stage.
And so, asyou move forward, once you've got your staging environment up, you've got it stable,
this is whenyou start incorporating all that customization, right?
And at this point you might not have one
Dev environment.
You might have 2,
you might have 3, you might have 4,
but really, it's getting allof your teams involved so that they're all working toward the same goal.
So, you've got this Stageenvironment, you're feeding Dev in,
and you say, "OK, well we're ready to really get into somereal testing, right?"
Well, in that case, we're now going to order
what will eventuallybe, but isn't today, the DR (Distaster Recovery) environment .
Because what's the purpose of having a DR if youdon't ever actually test it?
And so, not only are you going to start moving all of this intoyour DR environment,
but also let's go ahead and do a sync, right?
Let's get all that on-premisesdata that we've got,
and let's get it copied into our DR environment.
Because, as a DR site, it hasto work as production in the event of a disaster,
so it has to be the same specs as your productionsystem.
So, let's get a full data load into it, and let's start running some actual performance
testing.
Let's start running some actual load on it.
Let's start running some actual queries on it
to be sure that it does, in fact, solve the problems that you need.
Let's also be sure that all of
our data pathing is right.
Let's be sure that it has access to what it needs,
and that the datathat's flowing to it is flowing to it correctly.
Next, once we're happy here,
now we'regoing to move up and we're going to getour Pre-Prod systems up.
So, your Pre-Prod isgoing to be slightly downsized from production,
but the goal is confirmation testing, right?
Youreventual flow will be Dev, Stage, Pre-Prod, Prod.
But for now, we're going to stop in this DRenvironment,
we're going to do some testing, and we're going to get Pre-Prod stable, right?
We'regoing to get our DevOps path from Dev, to Stage, to Pre-Prod.
We're going to get that solid.
We're going to be sure that our release process is right.
We're going to be sure that our change
control is right,
because then it's time to go up
and let's get your production system which is themost important part, right?
So, you're going to go up to your Prod system,
and since you've gotProd, guess what? Time to bring data in again!
So, we're going to get another fresh copy of
data from our existing on-premises solution,
and we're going to get that loaded into
production, and then we're going to do
all of our end-to-end testing.
All of our useracceptance testing.
All of our criteria.
So that we can get to the holy grail of Go Live,
and the whole point of getting to Go Live,
is this is when you do your cut over, right?
You've already done your sync to Prod, so you've just got to get a little delta on yourdata.
Once you get that delta load, you're going to have to take some sort of a downtime outage
to cut over into your new production system.
Once you have done that, your environment is
up, it s stable, it's ready to go.
At that point you're going to go back into a normal Devcycle, right,
into that continuous integration, continuous release cycle
where you're feedingDev changes into Stage,
and you don't have to stop at DR anymore,
but your changes in Stageare going to go to Pre-Prod, Pre-Prod into Prod,
and then start back again.
So, all of thiswork is going to continue as time goes on,
and you're going to be in that wonderfulcycle,
but that's how you get from on-premises
into the cloud, in a way that is
hopefully solving all of your problems.
Thank you so much for
stopping by the channel today!
If you have any questions or comments,
please feel free to share them with us below.
If you enjoyed this video and you would
like to see more like it in the future,
please do like the video and subscribe to us
so that we'll know to keep creating for you.
If you have any questions about
evaluating or running SAP on IBM Cloud,
please go to ibm.com/cloud/sap or
click on the link in the description.
We'd love to talk more with you about how we can
help you solve your SAP on Cloud challenges.